all right and uh we're pleased to
welcome tonight professor gregory sadler
in case you couldn't read uh his
talk is aristotle's multidimensional
analysis of anger we'll run for a while
we'll do this thing we'll have some q a
and
please welcome
thanks so
you notice aristotle looking very
marshall here in this in this uh image
of him and this is actually
uncharacteristic
but it fits the the sense of anger and
sternness and all that um it's kind of a
funny image for me i like it because
aristotle and his followers were known
in ancient times for being kind of
snazzy dressers and being a little bit
on the soft side and aristotle was
actually faulted with wearing too many
rings you know
too much pride in his appearance so this
is a kind of an uncharacteristic image
of him but this is this is one that
you'll see on a lot of
websites
um
what i'm going to talk about
tonight i'm writing a book on aristotle
major
i'm going to talk about six different
dimensions to
anger as aristotle treats it in his word
but first before i do that i want to
talk a little bit about why i
researched this at all you know why is
it interesting
for aristotle anger has a unique status
and and this is
not just him there's there's other
theorists that you could think of you
know plato for example with females you
know however we're going to translate
that
having a particular role in moral
psychology also later on with with
people who were influenced by aerosol
elect thomas
aquinas anger is going to have a sort of
unique status among the passions or the
emotions of the soul
and one reason why it has this status is
because anger is uniquely concerned with
our sense of justice and injustice
a lot of the other passions are
concerned with
things that affect us
other moral values you know pleasure
pain
a sense of beauty
ugliness things being discorded but
anger is uniquely concerned with with
justice
i got interested in aristotle in part
because
aristotle's views on anger
in part because he is also
not unique but but he stands out in the
ancient world as being somebody who saw
anger is having a legitimate role in
moral life
and this again is tied in with the sense
of justice and injustice
as opposed to say
you know the stoics or
the epicureans or even
for the most part the plaintiffs anger
does have some role in
things there they tend to look at anger
as a bad thing
aristotle doesn't see anger as a good
thing you know where we should all be
angry all the time as much as we
possibly can
but he has a
he has a role for it in his in his
moral psychology and his ethics
he thinks that we ought to get angry at
certain times that if we don't get angry
in certain cases there's something wrong
with us
so
that's rather unique and that that
transposes itself
uh into the middle ages and into
discussions about anger which are
influenced by a lot of other factors we
can talk about that more in the q a
but aristotle's account coming through
um
really changes the picture so i'm
interested in it for that reason
aerosol is a kind of angry and is very
sophisticated
he doesn't just treat it
from one angle that's part of why i'm
doing this talk to begin with that's
because i
did more and more work and more and more
writing and thinking about this i came
to realize that aristotle was actually
treating anger from a variety of
different perspectives
throughout his different texts and that
these weren't really reducible to each
other
it also allowed me to do what i like to
call philosophical detective work which
is something i enjoy doing some of you
may enjoy doing as well
where you have to look across a person's
works
not aristotle never wrote a treatise on
anger
if you want to know what he thinks about
anger
you have to read
a bunch of different texts and you have
to put together a composite picture that
comes from them
so if you were only to go by what you
saw say in the rhetoric you know and
quite often philosophers don't read the
rhetoric
it's more
um political science people on the one
hand or or english people other than
philosophers don't often read it but if
you if you don't read it you miss a lot
of his
remarks about anger that fill in the
picture
likewise there's important remarks about
it in the politics in the two different
topics
so
you have to form a composite picture and
you have to do a lot of correlation of
things i like to do that so that's why
i'm writing about doing that
there are some challenges to studying
aerosol on anger some of these are
challenges that are inherent in studying
aristotle anyway
he wrote in greek
the greeks have a lot of different
terminology for anger
as a matter of fact there's two words
that aristotle uses almost
interchangeably you have to look at
individual circumstances to decide
whether you know they mean the same
thing one of them is
which region plato you know from the
republic is that that spirited
passionate
third thing in between reason
and the appetites and the other is organ
what often gets translated in other
texts as wrath but in the aristotelian
corpus is
his anger and the greek said some other
words for it too maintenance but
aristotle doesn't use those too much
then he uses an entire host of verbs for
anger
a lot more than just the the noun and he
uses a lot of different adjectives to
describe people being angry or how
they're angry and
part of the problem is when greek texts
are translated into english
these
these common ideas that you see
occurring in this text in this text in
this text they often get lost in
translation
because you'll have different people
translating the text looking at it from
different angles so if one person
translates the most as spirit and
another person translated as passion yet
another person translates it as anger
if you don't have greek you wouldn't
recognize that they're all talking about
the same thing and that is that that is
actually how the most has been
translated in a lot of these texts
another challenge is the fact that anger
is spread throughout eris levels texts
so you can't just go by what you get in
the nick of mccain ethics or in the
rhetoric of all those
probably two most important places to go
um the other thing is aristotle had
different things in mind when he was
looking at anger in these different
texts so um in the topics he's not
really interested in trying to define
anger except in insofar as he's
interested in how do you define anything
and he's using it as an example
in the nick of mccain ethics he's much
more interested in you know what are the
virtues and vices associated with it he
doesn't bother to define it for the nick
of mccain he figures well everyone knows
what anger is
um what it feels like to be angry and
the rhetoric he actually settles down
and gives you a definition but he's not
interested really in
you know whether a person is rightly
angry or wrongly angry he's interested
in
if you're a writer if you're an orator
how do you make the crowd angry when you
want to
and how do you quell that anger in them
if you want to so he's got all these
different frameworks that he's looking
at it through and that can make it
difficult i think for somebody
approaching this to
put all the pieces together and that's
so that's part of what my project is
trying to get
um i've got a few passages here
and if you look at these passages and
you had to sort of pick
what's his focus
what sort of
way of looking at things is he looking
at things in a physicalist
you know paying attention to the
material aspect way is he looking at
angers and emotion is he looking at it
as an explanation for human reaction is
he looking at it as a moral phenomenon
you can look at these and say well which
do they fit in you know the first one
shows you why anger is so important
it says every action must be due to one
or one or other seven causes chance
nature compulsion habit reasoning anger
or appetite so all human action this is
something he says in the rhetoric all
human action can be explained by
reference to
at least one of these probably a whole
bunch of them functioning together if
you want to have a
very realistic picture
that shows you anger
is is an important element the anger
there is the thumbos not not the orchid
but
there's no reason not to see it as
synonymous at that point
to be angry with the right person at the
right time and for the right purpose and
in the right way that's not within
everybody's power and that's not easy
a quote by the way that the book
emotional intelligence starts with
because goldman has read his aristotle
what would you say that one has to do
what do you think is that looking at it
from
just the emotion
is it looking at from a moral
perspective
is it interested in how we get
at the right time how should we be angry
bursts of anger or fits of terror when
once they've excited such motions are
not at once delayed even though the
angry or terrified person set up counter
motions but the passions continue
this is actually from one of the
the uh works about
the psyche
and this has a physical aspect if you
read further into that passage but this
is about human psychology
once we get angry is it easy for us to
stop being angry
it was you know saying back in
aristotle's time if you think about
things that make you angry you will
continue to be angry
anger is a desire accompanied by pain
for apparent retribution aroused by an
apparent sliding against oneself or
those connected to oneself with sliding
being undeserved there you have a
definition right
anger is and it tells you all this stuff
about anger
this is not about whether anger is right
or wrong
this is about
how can we define this emotion that we
experience
and you notice in order to define this
emotion he's got to throw a lot of
things in there anger is not a simple
emotion even though it feels simple to
us when we're experiencing it if we
analyze it it's actually quite complex
let me just get through these others you
get the point you can look at anger from
a lot of different perspectives
these are aristotle's texts that either
directly talk about anger or which sort
of
in a side passage
touch on anger
you notice there's a lot of them this is
this is a good part of the aristotelian
corpus
there's no one single test that if you
wanted to study this you would focus on
i would say if you had to pick
four it would be the rhetoric the two
ethics
and perhaps either on the soul or the
topics but
you would still leave some important
things out if you didn't read the
politics or if you didn't look right
um
why are there
poetics up there or the history of
animals the hearts of animals
or on memory around dreams
so
when i first started
writing about this
about close to 10 years ago
originally i thought of it in terms of
three
sort of overlapping dimensions by which
aristotle was analyzing anchor i could
see that he had an interest in what goes
on with us physically what goes on with
us with our body our soul
not a great interest in that by the way
but but some interested so there's
there's a level at which he's analyzing
anger and looking at how does the body
act when it's angry
and then he looked at the emotion um
what is anger like what causes it what
intensifies it with what you know dulls
it
to go away
so there's an emotional or psychological
level and that and the physical somatic
level are tied together for aristotle
aristotle doesn't think that we're sort
of disembodied souls just kind of
floating around until we smack into a
body he thinks that we are our bodies
now that the soul is the form of the
body so what goes on with our body when
we're getting angry is important it's
not the whole show
but it is tied together with that and
then it's you know it's clear that he
has some views about whether anger is
right or wrong good or bad and when
that's the case so there's a moral or as
i call it you're an ethical theoretic
and there's a lot of jargon so i'm just
going to go through and tell you a
little bit about this so there's a
physical somatic
level aristotle's trying to explain
what's going on with us in terms of
the physics of living things what we
call
biology right
there's an emotional or psychological
an ethical or pro-ironic level
pro-racist is aristotle's term for what
we often translate as deliberative
choice
in epictetus
it gets translated as moral purpose and
you can think of the pro-erasis as
the fabric of a person's character who
that person is
it's a product of the choices that they
habitually make it's what they bring
with them to each situation
there's some other dimensions too
that i found as
i was looking at this i tried to
shoehorn everything into these three
levels
and i found out that wouldn't actually
work there were some other things that
didn't seem to fit that well
and so i had to recognize some other
dimensions to it i'm actually
to be honest i'm still not entirely
happy with this scheme
uh particularly with the last one and i
think there may be some other dimensions
that have to be distinguished as well so
this is a work in progress
but there is a dimension to aristotle's
discussions of anger that has to do with
our will he doesn't use the term will
but you can understand it in those terms
and with practical reasoning what is how
does anger actually
work
what does it make us think about how
does it get us to do things
and then there's a political or legal
dimension to aristotle's treatments of
anger
it gets talked about in politics anger
is a major
cause for a lot of things in the
political scene you can look at today's
politics or look at 20 years ago or look
at any part of human history and you'll
see that working
then there's what i i sort of coined in
terms of was the responsive thoratic
thyrothyrosis is
not courage it's confidence in in
aristotle's terminology
it's the opposite of the feeling of fear
we have an anger response that all of
you have experienced uh it's tied in
with what we call a fight-or-flight
response right
when you're threatened or when you
perceive yourself as being threatened
sometimes if you're you know a
particularly good person you see another
person being threatened
something happens to you and it's a lot
of it is bodily but it's not just bodily
for aristotle
anger can look an awful lot like courage
aristotle says
and anger can also be part of our
temperaments so that's that dimension as
well and i like i said i'm not entirely
happy with
whether that's actually one
full dimension or not
but you know i have to think this out a
bit more
each one of these
provides intelligibility to our actions
part of why i wanted to study aristotle
in the first place is if i want to
understand
anger and how it works you know
among human beings and how it affects me
and how it affects my relationships with
other people i'm looking for
intelligibility i'm looking for
understanding of what's going on
um better i've ever been to
anger workshop
sessions or things like that part of
what you have to do is figure out what's
going on with you what takes place when
a person gets angry
so each of these provides some
intelligibility to things that we're
interested in each of these dimensions
in aristotle's account informs the
others
each of them is irreducible to the other
dimensions so aristotle doesn't think
there's one single thing to look at
that's the key to understanding
everything about anger
that's part of what attracts me to
to his position that might actually turn
some people off people who like things
to be very simple
aristotle is not going to be fair for
them
because aristotle sees that anger is a
complex
human emotion that's tied in with all
these
other parts of our life
so these are some of the implications of
that no one single dimension is going to
be the key you can't just look at the
rhetoric you can't just look at the
nickel mccain ethics
you can't say that anger is uniformly
unequivoc unequivocably good or bad or
works always in this way or anything
like that with aristotle
also if you want to have an adequate
understanding of anger fear is always
right about this
and i do think he's capturing a lot of
important
things
the adequate understanding would have to
take in all these different dimensions
so
so far as i can see this this hasn't
actually been done with with work on
aristotle there's some articles out
there about
aristotle and anger student life is an
important
thinker in that respect
there's a book out there that tries to
you know take the notion of
domos and use it for feminist
theory
about five years ago but nobody's
actually
just
seen what aristotle has to say about all
these different dimensions put it
together
this is a good example of what's going
on in there
in on the soul of the day
he says he's talking about anger and
he's not really interested in looking at
anger and trying to analyze it you know
down to its bones at that point he's
using this as an example he says you
know if you look at certain
psychological phenomena you can look at
them as a natural scientist you know
you can look at them as what he calls a
dialectical philosophy of the
electricals or another way of thinking
about that would be you know the
philosopher writ large you know the
moral philosopher
the natural philosopher and the
dialectical folks really define anger in
different ways
one is going to define it as a desire
for causing pain in return or something
like that you can tell he's being kind
of careless at this point he's not
interested in nailing it down he did
that in the rhetoric
that's a definition that's that's
similar to the rhetoric definition
that's an emotional definition it's
defining the pathos the emotion that we
feel
the other is a surge or boiling of blood
and heat around the heart
now that's a very physical description
of anger isn't it
do you ever think of anger as being a
surge or boiling of blood and heat
around your heart
that may actually kind of correspond to
your
experience of anger a little bit
if you feel do you feel your anger here
when you get angry
all of you get angry right
you feel maybe out here or something
like that
this is tied in with aristotle's biology
he's got this whole theory about you
know heat and the heart of blood and
what it does and we don't actually have
to buy into any of that to see how
you know this is kind of an interesting
thing he's trying to
look at it in that way
um
this is the way i i'm trying to
sort of conceptualize these and this you
know two-dimensional charts are they
ever gonna really capture a complex
phenomenon no
but what we've got is we've got a sort
of physical somatic basis that's always
great to be there so long as we're
beings that are bodily
and that's just sort of the start of the
show
the most
comprehensive level
is the political level for aristotle
because we are beings that live and have
our meaning in community
and you can't escape that for arizona
and then as we move
closer to
the actual phenomenon of anger you've
got this whole ethical dimension
of anger you know whether anger is good
or bad appropriate or inappropriate
right or wrong in this way and that
takes in these other things which which
in some way interact in
ways that aristotle never makes clear
with the physical basis
it's clear that he thinks that they do
interact it's very unclear precisely how
they would interact
so we don't have to worry about that too
much but these three things
they have ethical implications
but they're not directly
within that sphere and they are distinct
from each other they influence each
other but they
they are
topics that you can look at their their
own right so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to talk about each of these
dimensions
fairly quickly
and then we're going to look at using
these handouts um two of the dimensions
very quickly as well and then i'll take
some two
or comments or concerns or whatever so
the physical semantic level
like i said aristotle is not
particularly concerned with giving us
any sort of comprehensive understanding
if he did it probably wouldn't be any
good for us anyway because we don't buy
into his biology
right
we know that you know there's some
things connected to to anger that you
know our blood pressure doesn't actually
go up but it's not because the
human being is actually heating up and
the blood is getting hotter that's what
arizona thought
you know that's better than no theory at
all i think but it's not one that we
would find today
quite useful today aristotle does think
there's some sort of complex interaction
between the mind or the soul of the body
precisely what it is
he doesn't tell us uh and what it what
it is exactly for anger he's unclear
about as well
what he's doing here is something like a
phenomenological account not not a
husserlian phenomenology i just mean
he's paying attention to
experience as best as we could
draw on a draw on it at that time
and the key things that he's thinking of
with this physical level is movement
movement in terms of the heart being
affected or changed
heat
hotness and coldness you know if the
blood gets cold then we feel fear and
things like that when we get angry the
blood is hot that's why we get reckless
when we're angry
and
the circulation the blood itself
that's the ladies thinking of that and i
think you know this is important to look
at i'm not particularly concerned about
this
for the book
but i want to at least acknowledge it
then we have this very complex
treatment of aristotle
the heart of it is in the rhetoric but
it's spread throughout a whole bunch of
other works if you if you
look at the aristotelian text dealing
exploit explicitly explicitly with anger
you notice there's about
seven or eight different texts in which
he's talking about this
dimension he does devote a lot of
attention to this he's developing it
systematically
he does say a few things that we might
think are a little strange like he says
that people who are
people who are experiencing other
people's anger don't feel anger towards
them in return
which we know is not true because all of
you have probably gotten angry at
somebody from getting angry at you right
but almost everything else that he says
makes sense in some way he develops a
very complex definition of anger that
we're going to look at a little bit
later
portions of which get used in his own
work so he's presupposing this
he focuses he focuses on how anger gets
caused what makes it more or less
intense
and how it ends and in the rhetoric he's
interested in if you're
somebody who's communicating and you
want to manipulate emotions you need to
know about the emotions how do you
actually make people angry
what's the best way to do it how do you
direct anger so it doesn't end up
getting turned against you once you
arrive
that's an important thing to do
he also looks at connections between
anger and some other aff activities like
uh friendship and hatred that's that's
one uh set of opposites that he
ties in with the danger quite a bit
and also shame the sense of shame
that can often trigger
anger
or intensify it and he analyzes some
specific dimensions of anger which i
give you in the handout and we're also
going to look at a few of those later
too
so that's the that's the emotional
dimension then we have an ethical
dimension the dimension where we can
start talking about
not just how we feel or why we feel that
way but whether it's good or bad
whether it's right or wrong
he treats this systematically as well
in the two ethics and bits and pieces
and
and the focus there because aristotle's
a virtue ethicist is on analyzing it in
terms of virtues and vices what are
virtues and vices
those are good or bad habits or
dispositions
not produce actions emotions have its
choice attitudes or direct them or bind
them up together
they're part of you know what make us
the kind of people that we are he frames
it in terms of the right measure or the
mean
that's why he says you know it's not
easy to figure out how how angry you
ought to get
that's the right measure
and he distinguishes between a number of
distinct vices and virtues we often
present aristotle in a thumbnail
sketches that for any given
issue or action or emotion there's the
good virtue in the middle and then
there's a vice of deficiency they're not
enough and then there's the advice of
access to too much you know sort of like
the goldilocks story you know one
porridge is too hot when the forge is
too cold one of them's just right
when you actually look at aristotle he
does that with some things but he
doesn't do that with anger
that's that's another thing that makes
anger kind of interesting
he distinguishes
at least four different
vices of excess with anger
and why does he do that well because
he's not just throwing a schema out
there he's actually looking at what
happens when people get angry
how do they go wrong
how do they screw things up how they
screw themselves up
we need to be able to distinguish
between different modes of that
then there's this other dimension like i
said
one that i didn't recognize at first but
now i think has to be understood as a
distinct
way of looking at that anger in
aristotle
the volitional or practically rational
dimension and this one is very important
for aristotle but he never treats it
systematically
so we have to put together a picture out
of passages here and there
and it focuses on giving in to anger
as a mode of weakness of will that's
weak as well that's one aspect of it
sometimes we call this incontinence or
across
he also focuses on
how responsible is the person who's
getting angry
for what they do as an angry person
how much is in their control and how
much
is caused by something else that's
something that he's very interested in
analyzing and he looks at how does anger
affect our practical reason another one
of the things that's interesting about
anger
is aristotle says anger is more rational
than the other emotions
he actually likens it to his servants
who are
you know they're good servants but they
don't really pay attention to what's
being told them so they hear the very
first part of something and then they go
off and start doing it and sometimes you
know students do this with assignments
right you say you know write a five page
paper and
they go and they start writing it and
then they don't realize well i wanted
you to write this cat five page paper
right they had that this this and this
thing
um aristotle says angers like that
it seems that there's some sort of
insult or something you know going on
that bothers us and it jumps to the
conclusion i ought to hurt that person
or i ought to retaliate
it's carrying out a reasoning process
it's tied in with practical reasoning
but it gets it wrong in some in some
respects
then there's a political or legal
dimension and again this is not
systematically treated we have to
reconstruct this
anger has an important role in
politics for aristotle
not just for aerosol for a lot of other
political theorists as well
thomas hobbs for example thomas aquinas
anger has a
very important role in what aristotle
calls factional strife
the kind of
breakdown of society that takes place
not just along class lines or interest
lines or stuff like that but along moral
ones that destroys communities
anger has a very important role in that
so if you can understand anger well you
could potentially intervene and
maybe keep that from happening
he also focuses on laws governing the
violent actions or words that arise from
anger
eris level sees a role for laws and
curbing vice and promoting virtue some
people say you can't legislate morality
aristotle would say
that's part of the point of legislating
as a matter of fact that's the main
point of legislating
and he's you know pretty characteristic
of
ancient and evil thinkers in that way
he also focuses on anger as a more or
less understandable cause for wrongdoing
in legal affairs so on the rhetoric for
example he'll
say well you know maybe your your client
um
got himself in trouble
precisely because he was angry and
you're going to argue before the jury
about what he did and say well it's not
that big of an offense because the
consequences were bad but his you know
anger was moving in it wasn't just
malice or a bad character or something
like that
but that's a political dimension i think
because it has to do with the way we
live together
and then finally there's this other
dimension which again i
maybe this is just sort of a
miscellaneous
uh junk junk drawer kind of thing where
i'm throwing too many things in that
don't actually belong together but these
seem to be related to me i'm perfectly
you know willing to hear why they're not
connected at all or why i should you
know treat them as separate issues
anger is a response to danger
and
aristotle says it produces
confidence it mutes fear and ties in
with the virtue of courage as a matter
of fact when he's
talking about these five different types
of
courage
that
are not exactly the virtue of courage
but are kind of like it
anger
and incidentally love being motivated by
love you know saying protecting your
children who you love or your wife or
your husband who you love
those are like courage
those are a type of church
he also focuses a lot in his discussion
of the parts of animals and things like
that
on temperaments and he says something
really interesting that i want to
share with you
which
i think is
it's not distinctive to aristotle but it
does express him well
he thinks that different animals have
different temperaments i think that we
would more or less agree with him we
would say that a cat
cats in general behave in different ways
than dogs in general behave
which behave differently than say
rats you know
whether you know whether it's more
malleable than aristotle thought i i
suspect that
that's the case
aristotle thought that certain animals
were
more choleric more prone to getting
angry towards exhibiting violent
behavior that sort of thing like bulls
for example and he had a physical
explanation for it the bowl has a lot
more fibers in its its you know body and
its heart and that transmits the blood a
lot easier and so therefore you know
it's able to get hotter quicker and all
that we can we can put all that aside
right
so aristotle thinks that
different animals have different
temperaments some are very nice and
gentle
some are you know prone to anger
some are
more loving all that sort of stuff
he says human beings are different
um we could be any of these ways
and we're unlike the other animals not
only because we have logos or you know
speech or reason
but because we're more differentiated
than they are
we can potentially be like any of these
things that the animals
uh can be like
um and this leaves a door open to
what gets called the theory of the
temperaments which makes its way into uh
medieval thinking about
how the body is connected with our
emotions and things like that as well
again i don't know if this really should
come as a dimension on its own but i'm
willing to for the time being while i'm
working on the book call it that
once again here's that that schema that
i came up with now we've gone through
them
these are how i see them being connected
with each other
now i'd like to talk a little bit before
we
we can start doing a q a about um
a few of these dimensions just little
bits and pieces of things
so this isn't this is part of the
emotional dimension this is the rhetoric
definition of anger
you notice it's quite complex
there's
and the greek
transliterated
uh characters are not showing up as well
in powerpoint which is which is a shame
so aristotle says anger is a desire a
type of desire auraxis is the most broad
term that that we have for desire and
nurses
accompanied by pain anger is painful
it's not just painful to be angry
you get angry because you get hurt right
quite often
it's a desire for what for what he calls
a parent retribution and this term of
parent
binomials it could mean
retribution that's visible that we get
to see retribution that you think is
retribution maybe you're not actually
affecting the person but so long as you
can think yeah i got them back
it's you know apparent retribution
aroused by now you notice that same term
showing up apparent sliding
sliding is a term
that you might say well that that's not
really what gets me angry getting
slighted but if you understand what
aristotle means by that it's
which means sort of you know to
lessen somebody to
some of the forms of it cataphronesis to
look down upon somebody to treat
somebody as if they don't count as if
they're not as valuable as you are
but a parent's life notice
anger doesn't have to actually be
inspired by an actual sliding all it
takes is that the person think that
they've been
negatively affected in some way treated
as less than that they want to be
treated or is having less value and
they're often they're angry
this is you know this can fit in with
the moral aspect maybe people who get
angry too too quickly there's something
wrong with the apparent part there right
um and who
who do you get upset about
do you get upset about
sliding against anybody out there on the
street if you do you're probably going
to be a very angry person
we tend to get angry about things that
have to do with ourselves or people that
are connected with us
and these can even be people we don't
like
you know
sometimes people will get angry
when somebody else disparages one of
their family members who they don't like
but it's their family member so
you don't get to talk about them that
way and they exhibit the anger response
right
the other thing that's really key to
this is that the sliding is undeserved
at least in their view
maybe this lighting is actually observed
maybe some people you know behave like
jerks and they should be treated like
jerks but then they get angry when they
get treated like jerks don't they
because they think they don't deserve to
be treated like jerks
this notion of desert this is what ties
angry with justice
and injustice
and aristotle thinks that this is
involved in every
instance in some way or another
now notice all these different
components there some of these are what
we would call judgmental or perceptive
or perhaps you might want to say
cognitive
some of them are purely affected
aristotle does think anger involves
pleasure too he doesn't have that in the
definition but he almost immediately
after that and the rhetoric talks about
the pleasure of being angry and this is
why some people can get addicted to
anger
he actually quotes a verse i think it's
from homer where he talks about anger as
being sweet as honey from the cone
i think that's from the iliad
but you notice all of these things are
involved without us realizing we're not
just you know really knowing what's
going on
and are getting angry
um
i'm not going to go through all these
dynamics this just gives you an idea of
the sophistication of aristotle's
attentiveness
he says
people can get angry at a person not for
what they in fact do or have done but
what for but for what one assumes they
are likely to do or will
we sometimes get angry as future pets
we get angry at people
um not for what they've actually done
the past the dimension of actually
there's also justice and injustice but
for
um what we think they're gonna do or
maybe they'll do it or they're the kind
of person who is here we can exhibit the
anger response for that
people also get angry when another
person prevents their hinders or even
fails to help when they feel it's due to
them that was something that they want
even bothering the person in a state of
unsatisfied desire can make them angry
we've all had the experience of trying
to get something done
and somebody bothering us and we blow up
at them
or if you haven't had that because
you're a good person uh somebody's done
that to you right
aristotle was noting this back in his
time
this is kind of a side note sometimes
people will say oh you know we can't
talk about the emotions of ancient times
because they lived a very different life
than we did you know really we can't
talk about the emotions of anyone and
they'll set you know various boundaries
from from 1800 before or
or 1700 or 1600
it doesn't appear that way the things
that aristotle are saying are the
dynamics of anger that we can recognize
in our own time and if we you know do a
lot of historical reading we can
recognize them in almost any time and
you can see this cross-culturally impact
people get angry when events go contrary
to their expectations
um now you know does that mean that some
there's an actual target of this person
wrong them
people get angry at the wind
people get angry at the lotto because
they didn't win it
you know people can get angry and feel
themselves slighted or wronged in some
way from all sorts of things when i was
a kid i used to i used to kick a tractor
that wouldn't start when i wanted it to
completely stupid behavior
you know but that was that was sort of
typical anger response
um this is a really interesting one
people become angry when what they value
or literally in greek what they take
very seriously
to take seriously the studies have zeal
about um it's what we actually get the
the word sprudios meaning sort of a
person who's earnestly trying to be a
good person
when what they are interested in or care
about is denigrated or treated
contemptuously by others
like if you're into stamp collecting and
somebody talks bad about stamp
collecting you're probably going to get
angry
and i didn't put this up here but
aristotle has another remark that makes
this even more interesting which i think
is also true
a person who feels themselves very
secure in say philosophy won't get upset
when philosophy is just disparaged
a person who feels themselves
not quite so good at it or you know
maybe
on their way or
you know they
think that others are
not seeing them in the way that they
want to they will get angry about it so
people who
are insecure about stamp collecting will
get angrier when you disparage stamp
collecting than somebody who's just fine
you know
what they do
so that's the the emotional dimension
that leads us naturally into this
ethical dimension
what matters with with virtue of isis
these are all the things that aristotle
says matters when it comes to anger
how one is angry
the motive you might say
with whom one is angry do we ever get
angry at the wrong people
i see it happen all the time i do it
you know
i think we've all done that
sometimes we're angry at one person and
then another person
just
says hello now we're angry at them too
right where we think that they're
they're you know tied in with this other
person that we're angry at um on what
grounds why do we get angry
aristotle thinks there's some things
that we ought to get angry about there's
other things probably most things that
we're getting about that we shouldn't
get anybody about
how long this is a big
is our natural tendency to hold on to
anger longer than we should or to let it
go quicker
what do you think
quicker right
no
longer now this is every culture just
about
up to what point one is right or errors
in being angry
this is a hard one for you to figure out
angry people
think that they're doing the right thing
that's part of what it is to be angry
you know there's something about anger
that clouds your judgment changes your
evaluation of the situation so now the
anger is like fully justified
that's part of what makes it so
productive
these are
some of the
dispositions that aristotle talks about
not all of them in the nicholas
there's people who are quick tempered
they get angry quicker than they want to
with the wrong people over the wrong
things but one good thing about this
kind of vicious disposition
is they get older and quick
so these are hotheads
you may know some hot hotheads
hot heads you can probably work with
you just
get out of the situation
and you come back and
now they're okay
not so with the rageful yeah holy they
get angry quickly and over everything
and it doesn't necessarily go away
and so you might think of these people
as the people who their whole
life is just you know
shot through with anger
then there's the bitter tattoo you know
these two they remain angry for a long
time uh why because they keep their
anger in when you're angry you desire to
have some sort of
you know setting things straight what
aristotle calls timorases we translate
it as retribution
or
revenge or there's a lot of r words that
we
use with that
these people keep their anger in and
they become resentful they guard their
anger but they're going to find some way
to get it and the picoid picross means
means sort of bitter or piercing
think of like that the taste is a taste
word that's actually used in greek for
certain kinds of food um
these are the kind of people who
you can tell that they're angry they
won't come out and tell you until
they're able to take their
their retribution
and there's the trouble i actually you
know translated this facetiously in some
writings as pains in the asses they just
make trouble about things they're always
unhappy they're grumbling about things
they become troublesome
more than they should that's a verb
that's used for a particular kind of
anger in greek for a longer time and
they won't be reconciled without some
sort of retribution or punishment
and then finally of the people who just
you know go out and start beating people
up
or swearing or doing all sorts of things
those are the the violent or the abusive
they engage in retaliation right away
and what aristotle means by calling them
vicious is this is part of their
character
these are the people who get in get a
lot of bar funds
things like that
they're the people that you see on cops
sometimes
now you know there's it's also possible
to go wrong although you notice there
aren't five different ways of going
wrong with respect to the bison
deficiency
aristotle actually only talks about one
way
you don't feel anger when you should
you don't feel as much of it as you
should
you accept insults and humiliating
treatment
at one point it says they don't get
upset when you strike them that's you
know that's pretty
experiential language right there
they feel the pain associated with anger
but you know not as much as they should
or not as quickly or not for the right
time this is a very different sort of
ethic than you might find in say
medieval monasticism
right where once
christianity and judaism and islam start
starting fusing their way into
philosophy there are little things if
you don't get angry when somebody
strikes you there's something wrong in
the situation
you shouldn't accept insults and
humiliating treatment
and so this is
a vicious disposition and then we have
the
virtuous disposition and there's
different ways of translating this
gentle is one way to translate it good
tempered mild
here's a kind of interesting bit of
connected dots stuff
what gets translated in the in the bible
is meek
in the greek stuff it's the same word as
the word aristotle is using that we
translate as good
you know in the septuagint when it says
moses was me it's problems
same as this
and then they talk about the meek
inheriting the earth it's the prowess
the most very proud it takes
there's different conceptions of how one
would be
mild or weak i think going on but it's
the same term the same thing
going on with that it does have to do
with being forgiving
this person either does feel an act from
the emotion
but they do so
in these ways they get angry at the
right time to the right degree with the
right people
as quick as they ought to for as long as
they want to there's all these different
qualifications and there's no you know
easy recipe for evolving you know in
this situation you should get exactly
this angry it's something that you have
to learn
through modeling experiential
it probably could help to have somebody
who
you look to that you think actually has
a good disposition with respect to anger
give you some advice about what's going
too far at this point you're not going
far enough at this point
they feel the pain and anger so they do
actually feel that this this kind of
person but as they watch it to the
degree that they ought to
and he says this is a really interesting
thing they're not disposed to punish but
to forgive
the word that he's using for forgiveness
and all men
is not the same word as forgiveness in
the new testament which is a different
greek
greek verb
um
afini
and aristotle does use that word at one
point but for the most part he uses this
language as soon as which we might not
necessarily think in terms of like
you know we're giving
seven times seven or anything like that
you know bending over backwards kind of
forgiveness but just sort of letting
something slide
oftentimes if you can let something
slide
when you would be tempted to get angry
about it you'll find looking back at it
later that you won't actually get angry
about it
the person who has a virtuous
disposition will do that
more often
or they may actually feel the emotion
slightly or not at all and they act from
reason this is much more rare the person
who
i don't know if this person exists a
person who actually doesn't feel angry
but
behaves like a person who gets angry to
the right degree takes the right sort of
retribution at the right time
he talks about this person as being calm
atheroxo so the verb that's used later
on
by the stoics and the epicurean not
driven by the emotion but as reason
ordains i'm not quite sure what to make
of this myself
um whether this you know
maybe there's something more going on
here in this this this description but
i'm not quite sure
so now i'll take whatever questions
you've got or suggestions complaints
i think the whole discussion is
fascinating has a lot to have to do i
think with war
i don't know what he observed but
certainly the greeks were involved with
war a lot
yeah
aristotle talks about courage
and the
the exemplar of courage and battlefield
courage
and the the aspect of anger where it
mutes fear and
promotes confidence
that's something i think he he thinks is
very important so you know you probably
want to get your troops angry at the
enemy
because otherwise they're going to be
scared of having these spears run
through them
and all the noise and things like that
the other thing that he says that's
really interesting is in the politics
he's using he's not using the term war
game for angry he's using thumbos which
could mean something a bit broader
and he talks about the different
barbarians and the greeks and the greeks
it's one of those sort of you know too
much too little just right
the southern barbarians so egyptians
syrians people like that
they don't have enough thermos so
they're slavish they're willing to let
people push them around and tell them
what to do and not fight back not get
angry and the people to the north you
know like the celts
who at that time were real holy terrors
for the two degrees um
people like that they've got too much
tumors
as a matter of fact they'll even he says
they'll fight the waves they'll go out
and you know i don't know if there's any
truth to this all but aristotle
apparently must have gotten the idea
from somebody that the celts would you
know just fight anything that moved
right
um
the greeks have just the right amount
which makes them the ideal soldiers
this is a he's writing at a time when
alexander is
trauming
the
persian empire
you know and he's doing it with
macedonian troops who are considered to
be
more you know thematic than um
the more subtle athenians and you know
the ones that have worn themselves out
the macedonians were seen as like one
step away from barbarians by the rest of
the greeks
so yeah words i think
you know another thing to think about is
what happens to soldiers when they come
home aristotle doesn't worry about this
at all
but
being a soldier a wartime soldier means
training yourself to get that anger
response going
how do you how do you adapt back to
barracks or then civilian life
afterwards
it could be something you can talk about
but he doesn't talk about it
yeah um i'm a little bit curious
remember what you said the agreed term
was but where it gets translated as meek
in the septuagint
oh
um
do you think that's a good difference of
translation there or do you think it
should be interpreted differently in one
or the other
well i think that if you look at
somebody like moses
moses you know got mad
when we think of somebody being meek we
think of somebody
um
never doing that putting up with it
i'm not even sure that
the new testament
should be necessarily seen as the person
who will put up anything whatsoever
you know just suck it all up you know
take it over and over and over again
so i think
i would like to maintain a distinction
in translation but i'd like to say he's
under more closely related
moses you know he's the most meek man
you know in the
to lead them into subjuga
and you know kill an egyptian
you know he sees injustice being done
and things like that so obviously it
doesn't preclude
um
some sort of righteous anger
yeah do you find criticisms of
aristotel's theory of anger in
the other schools of like say
hellenistic philosophy and if so does it
shed any light on
the theory or
help you piece together theory uh
because you're
you explain very well and about the
entertainment and various different
forms of parentals
i haven't looked at
explicit criticisms
in later
thinkers
but i think i think that would be
important
you know another thing that i didn't
bring up with this is there's more texts
about angular they're not directly or
they're written by aristotle's followers
and then they get contributed to aerosol
problems
um
and so there's there's there's a
continuing tradition about looking at
that
um
yeah i just i haven't looked into that
yet but i think it would be it would be
important
to do
um
i mean we know from the stoic moral
theory in general that anger was a real
problem for them
um seneca has a
piece on it
you know against against
giving in any real sway epictetus says
you know shouldn't be angry at all
it's never going to be good
for them or for epicureans
yeah i'm sorry
we were talking about the physical
theory and the sort of like blood
heating up and boiling around the heart
and whatever do you think that uh and
that ties into just his more his broader
physical theory that
uh there's her evidence at least that
like it goes both ways kind of with that
where like anger probably may have
played a role in his formulation of that
theory at all because i mean i think
those are feelings that we can all kind
of understand it seems like kind of a
weird
idea to get from any other emotion you
know
well um courage involves your confidence
thyroid
thyroid involves the blood being hot and
it's the opposite of
fear
so it's not the only one that he talks
about with that
um
i don't know i'm not i'm not a
specialist on
arizona's physical works i'm interested
in primarily
um
which the anger is primarily something
aristotle the bulk of aristotle's work
is is looking at
the emotional ethical and volitional
aspects of its political implications
yeah
so i'm wondering about the relationship
between
the uh
what you're referring to is the
volitional practical uh practical
nationality perspective here the
dimension and
the response
and i'm wondering if these are just
really just two sides of the same
dimension if that makes sense on the one
hand when you have any particular input
that you're getting from the responsive
theoretic yeah which results in certain
sorts of outputs which are what you're
getting with the volitional
the volitional practically rational
dimension and if maybe you could just
collapse them into one dimension which
would be agential or something like that
yeah i don't think aristotle i don't
think aristotle's idea about practical
reasoning is an input output kind of
thing yeah um
there
the the the sort of responsive or
theoretic dimension is definitely a
response that takes place and it is sort
of a stimulus response
but then it's what do you do with it
and
what i'm looking at with that that other
dimension is more
how does how does anger get us to think
about the things that food wants us to
think about rather than like how does it
subordinate reason to itself you might
say
rather than um how does it sort of like
put reason out of the picture entirely
um and then
how does how does it overcome
um
aristotle doesn't have a will per se but
you know
he does have this this notion of
lacrossia and a can be from anger where
we actually know what the right thing to
do is so there's a cognitive aspect to
it not just a
affective uh aspect
and um
yet we get moved and we don't do
the right thing either by
sort of weakness or impetuousness
i know the person's wavering there right
there's some there's some there's some
possibility of thinking i should do
something better than this you know you
might think of it as like here's the
stimulus and the response goes on and
that's sort of at an automatic
effective level yeah and then above it
is reason they can actually say hey
don't do this right you know not gonna
watch
take a deep breath you know something
like that
uh
i'm sorry oh good well
oh you wanna
you wanna continue better yeah i just to
just follow up with that sorry yeah uh
because because i was thinking about
things that he says
it sounds a little bit more
i don't use the word functionalist
because that's that's of course that's
that's going to be backgroundistic but i
mean it looks a lot more like that sort
of a picture that you get in
contemporary philosophy where you do
have
right you've got desires that are going
to be a response yeah to things in one's
environment and then they're causally
producing certain sorts of behaviors in
an agent and so that's where i would
guess i was wondering about the that's
why i'm suggesting that that particular
connection between the two well there's
causality there
that's clear
and there is
there is some sort of causal interaction
between the body and what's going on
with that and
the psyche
um but it's back and forth
for aristotle
and often murky ways especially
in the
uh
console
um
i don't know maybe maybe i'm just not
understanding his
position on this well enough well i'm
not claiming any expertise here at all
yeah and it seems to me that
we have desire or axis but auraxis is a
rexus is is a catch-all term that
includes um
four different things for aristotle
three of them he says very explicitly
over and over again our x's is epithelia
desire itself you know appetite fumos so
this whole whatever we're going to call
that anger the thematic the erasable
appetite and then oasis
uh and that's a bit murkier itself
exactly what who made it the levels this
is um
it's a friendship fits in with
hatred fits in with
other things and then pathos the
emotions themselves are our
types of
desire as well so we've got a different
types of
desires so within in the dianoma or like
in
you know nick and mccann that's book six
when he's saying
um you know we have desire and then
that drives things and then we use
reason
it's not just one kind of desire and
some of that desire is already
rationalized who that is rational
i think what we have to do is like
reconstruct how these things are cells
giving us an underdetermined account we
have to reconstruct
how these things actually fit in with
each other
and maybe the best way to do it is with
something like anger where we're looking
just at one kind of thing rather than
trying to come up with a whole
comprehensive
theory
you hate to come up with a good theory
and then find out that some some other
restitution text country gets different
it's
i was thinking a little bit about the
way you
drew your schema
and wondering whether or not there might
be alternative way of doing that so
let's go forward oh yeah i'm sure
so it seems to me and maybe this
in some way probably is your
idea of dimensions
um
so i i thought that
you could look at this and say well look
what central where it belongs at the top
or something that is what you're calling
the emotional definition
right like this is
first of all the central aspect of this
then all these other things
are basically figuring out
uh applications in this definition right
so you know you take player hooking uh
the design right you have a definition
it says okay a desire right then you
talk about when is this desire
appropriate uh what what counts as a
slight and what you know what should you
view as a slight uh which kinds of
slaves are
undeserved which aren't right so i mean
could you just make the definition
primary and say everything else he's up
to is just a way of
thinking about aspects of this thing
that he's got in place
because
i do think in terms of these dimensions
that inform each other and i think that
for aristotle it's very clear that the
the um
ethical and political or are more
encompassing
and there are pieces of architectonic um
so they aren't right it's not just
you've got a definition and then you
know sort of applications of it
you know it would be good to play around
with that
and find there's no way to represent
in a two-dimensional thing how
interpenetrating dimensions fit in with
each other
and um
but i don't want to come up with either
i don't know what i'm going to do
actually sort of thing
maybe yeah you know
maybe the thing to do actually
this means juggling chapters
is to say okay we're going to make this
primary like with making the rhetoric
definition and
the dynamics of the emotion primary and
then what would follow if we did make
this primary
here's how this would play out here
and then maybe look at what if we make
the birch advice aspect of the primary
there's a sign up too you know
as i've gone on writing this the book
has been sort of reconfigured a couple
times as i figure out that i've gotten
it more or less wrong and different
and the ways i've been arranging things
so
i guess i'll know that it's that it's
done when i
no longer
shuffle them around you had a question
too
um
because i don't really work on
emotions or agency or anything like that
but what i always find interesting about
anger is
people who don't have it but it's not
the badness of that isn't their mildness
it's their cold rational retribution
that doesn't seem a company bank like
the god
it has like passive aggressive anger or
just like okay jimmy come here you know
and then you send him out i'm gonna
because he
kills the guy or whatever but it's like
you don't see any anger at all and i
just wondered if
aristotle would actually call that
hatred and then
the rhetoric
he talks about the difference between
anger and hatred
and
um
he uh he says anger wants retribution
and it's easy there's something better
about anger because it wants its
retribution up front
and hatred can be without
injury can be cold and it can bide its
time and anger wants to see the person
punished hatred wants that the person
not exists
to
another thing that's interesting about
aristotle
where i think he's gone wrong and where
some of the other thinkers
either you know pre-christian like
stoics and and
people like that or some of the
christian thinkers who are treating this
aristotle doesn't think anger is likely
to lead to hatred
other thinkers say yeah if you're angry
long enough you're going to start hating
the person that you're angry with you
know if you don't resolve it
that's why augustine says we've got to
get rid of anger as soon as we can
because
anger by itself is not necessarily that
bad but the hatred that's going to come
from it if you let it sit there it is
going to it's going to pervade your soul
you know
yeah
another thing i should point out i don't
think that aristotle's
account is comprehensive so i think that
we would we would have to sub in some
some things that he just
didn't treat
could he have treated them probably but
and there's a lot of things where we can
use other parts of aristotle's text for
he's talking directly about amy and say
well this is how he might have addressed
that sort of thing
but he just didn't remember what we've
got is
huge but it's still fragmentary
so
it's unfortunate it wouldn't be nice to
have all of their assaults works
oh yeah um
does you ever talk at all about the sort
of practical benefits of being angry
which is kind of the opposite side of
some of the stuff that we've been
talking about the congress
uh like the motivational aspect of anger
or i mean obviously the
not letting people mistreat you if you
yeah like being courageous would be
another but i mean there are a whole
host of them i think
ultimately what else do you think
to get an idea what else do you think
anger is good for what why would you
want to um
thinking of that individual's piece for
instance where he sean nichols talks
about this
case apparently where there's a bunch of
people that are
like uh they're all on computers
basically and they're playing this
economic game where
um basically they
every time someone puts money in the pot
they lose money from their personal
staff then everybody who's in the game
gets some of that money that's in the
box okay so it's beneficial for each
person to not give it all and
um beneficial for all the others
whenever someone other than themselves
it does give into the pot okay i'm not
doing a very good job explaining that um
but the he says the way the games work
is that in the first number of series
there's no option for a punishment and
nobody ever gives because they don't
want to lose anything out of their own
pocket and then they
these people basically add a dimension
where they say now you can economically
punish the other people they interview
them and they all say that like they're
angry when no one else gives or when
someone gives less than everyone else's
and all of a sudden contributions are at
like 90 some percent
and the conclusion is moral angers of
beneficial
sort of emotion in a lot of different
ways and that would be one of them
where you're like increasing cooperation
and kind of
getting certain actions out of other
people that
yeah aristotle doesn't ever talk about
that directly
but anger has a kind of
you might say regulatory role in making
us do the right things we act like jerks
other people get angry at us and then we
realize you know we better not act like
that or we're gonna
have all these consequences we don't
like um
but anger is always dangerous
you know
anchors sort of like a
controlled burning
for aristotle
you know it's great it does a lot of
important things
and it's nice to look at the fire too
either you know there's a certain
pleasure of that but if the wind goes
wrong or you didn't set up the the
trenches you know right if you're sort
of just playing around with the kid
walking around doing i'm going to do a
controlled burn who starts lighting
things on fire now it's going to be all
sorts of trouble
and you know his society too was a
society where
um
there was way more anger
going out of control and screwing things
up then
but yeah i think i think you could talk
about that from a wristband perspective
he thinks that praise and blame are are
really essential to how we learn about
the riches
another thing i didn't talk about in
here
when it comes to the arousing of anger
he talks about the role of omasis in the
poetics and also in the politics
he doesn't go into it in great detail
but
he seems to think that we ought to have
depictions of people getting angry that
they serve some sort of role
you know but but it's you know again he
is
just cutting down
if you want to know uh i've got a few
writings about aristotle and the
emotions and anger i've got um in
academia that eu
say right in my portfolio um i also if
you're interested in the aristotle i
record my
lectures that are given classes and so
they'll be on youtube and i've talked a
bit about it on some belongings as well
so thanks for your uh your attention and
your questions